in 1963 the cold war between the United
States and the Soviet Union started to
escalate and the dropping of another
nuclear bomb looked imminent realizing
that Humanity could be wiped out the
then U.S President John F Kennedy came
up with a secret plan to ensure its
survival he along with the help of a
group of scientists launched a large
spaceship called the Ascension this
spaceship host 600 volunteers and the
mission was to colonize a planet in the
Centauri Proxima the journey is set to
take 100 years so the mission is set out
to be a challenging one the scene then
cuts to two generations later the
spaceship is now filled mostly with the
grandchildren of the original 600
volunteers however the basic
surroundings still feel like the 1960s
it has been 51 years since the spaceship
was launched and to commemorate the
special day a party has been thrown
looking at the inhabitants including
chief executive officer Aaron Gold it is
clear that the mission has been a
success so far they seem to have become
accustomed to the Norms of the spaceship
however life is not so so simple for
everyone aboard the Ascension the
wealthy and affluent families are given
good job positions and live on the upper
decks while the poor are limited to the
lower decks meanwhile a young woman
named Lorelei is seen picking up a
package from a shady looking butcher she
then goes swimming at the ship's
artificial Beach unfortunately after a
while a little girl named Krista finds
her dead body and starts screaming
[Music]
meanwhile on Earth it is revealed that
the chief engineer behind the spaceship
is still alive however due to his weak
State his son Harris has taken his place
we also get to know that the Ascension
project is still a well-guarded
government secret Harris regularly
receives updates from the ship and
tracks down their progress one day he
eventually learns about lorelei's murder
and his assistant advises him to brief
the Project's director Catherine Warren
about it however Harris fears it could
jeopardize the project and tarnish his
father's Legacy back on the ship Dr
Juliet Bryce chief medical officer
examines the dead body and concludes
that Lorelei was probably murdered
because of the marks on her wrist so the
ship's Captain William assigns gold to
the responsibility of investigating the
case Galt immediately starts his
investigation and finds something
mysterious because there are no cameras
inside the beach he checked the ones
outside however not a single one of them
captured the moment that Lorelei entered
the beach later gold learns that Lorelei
was dating a guy named James tobac who
works at the Water Reclamation in the
lower decks so he goes looking for him
but to no avail the same day forensics
experts reveal that Lorelei made love
some hours before her death a small
puncture is also found on the roof of
her mouth it is revealed to have been
made by a special bullet which was
powerful enough to kill her but not to
pierce through her skull and eventually
the spaceship this alarm's Gult is
officially there are no guns on board
the ship immediately he discusses the
updates with Captain William the latter
is equally shocked as no guns have been
seen in 51 years ever since the ship
left Earth on the other hand the little
girl Krista is admitted to the medical
center as she went into a State of Shock
after discovering lorelei's body she
continuously claims that someone's
watching her with days passing by she
begins to recover but starts making wild
claims Krista alleges that there's no
life in space so they should return back
to Earth she also alleges that Lorelei
was afraid of someone because of
something she had found out it appears
as if the girl can see things than
others can't eventually apprehends James
Tom back and forces him for answers the
latter admits that he was with Lorelei
on the day she died however she abruptly
left after they got into an argument
tobac also reveals that he didn't make
love with her before her death after the
Revelation gold takes him to the beach
and the two start looking for Clues
suddenly they stumble upon a secret
passage which was apparently used by
Lorelei on her death day this explains
why the CCTV cameras outside didn't spot
her in the next scene golt and fellow
officer Duke who also happens to be
lorelei's brother-in-law inspect the
alternate Beach entrance it is a dark
alley but they ultimately locate the
spot where she was murdered as the two
continue searching they also find a book
with maps of the water filtration system
and nav computer blueprints it turns out
the nav computer crashed a month ago and
the water filtration system also went
offline a week ago this clearly proves
that they were sabotaged Captain
Williams suspects that the saboteurs
want to force the ship back to Earth
Duke and his men then perform a raid of
the lower decks there the butcher from
earlier Stokes opposes the raid and
instigates a fight however before
someone gets killed an alert starts
going off which reveals that the ship is
heading towards a massive radiation
storm because of this radiation
Protocols are put into immediate effects
and everyone is ordered to take shelter
in their pods unfortunately the captain
learns that the blast Shields that are
supposed to protect the crew from
radiation are jammed so a repair team is
immediately assembled which consists of
gold and an electrician from the lower
decks thanks to their team effort the
door is eventually closed before
departing the electrician confides to
Gold that he saw Stokes giving Lorelei a
gun before she was murdered at the same
time Dr Juliet puts little Krista to bed
and leaves her seahorse necklace on the
dresser to calm her down claiming that
it will protect her however after a
while when the spaceship enters the
radiation Zone and all the people get
inside their radiation pods Christa sees
a strange man in a suit walking in her
room after the ship safely passes
through the storm and everyone is
cleared to come out golden Duke again
raids stoke's slaughterhouse they
eventually locate a gun and take Stokes
into custody later the butcher is
interrogated but he keeps claiming that
he's being set up because he's from the
lower deck and an easy scapegoat
meanwhile Dr Juliet looks for her neck
Krista tells her that someone took it
during the storm one day before
lorelei's funeral little Krista
approaches Galt and hands him an army
metal she tells him that it was given to
Lorelei by her boyfriend this stuns gold
as the medal belongs to Captain William
meanwhile the door to Stokes his prison
cell automatically opens he is puzzled
and scared for his life so he nervously
walks out and retrieves the gun from
earlier after the funeral ends gold
confronts the captain for answers
William admits that he was fooling
around with Lorelei but also promises
that he didn't kill her just then Stokes
shows up holding a girl hostage he again
claims that he's being set up and
demands to be taken before the council
out of nowhere the airlock opens
automatically and gold lunges at Stokes
freeing the girl the captain swiftly
takes her to safety and locks the door
as Stokes and gold continue fighting
after a bit of back and forth Stokes is
sucked out into space but surprisingly
instead of freezing in an instant he
lands on an inflated mattress after
which a group of people apprehend him
here we get to know that the whole
project is a mere simulation a test of
the long-term viability of an
intergenerational space flight the
people on board the spaceship are
completely oblivious of it as they
believe that they have been sent on an
important Mission back on Earth director
Warren somehow finds out about the
latest developments on the ship enraged
she storms into mission control and
warns Harris against hiding things
Harris claims that Stokes is the Killer
and now he has been evicted from the
ship however director Warren isn't
convinced and she sends a consultant
named Samantha Kruger to watch over the
project much to the dismay of Harris the
scene then cuts to an unknown man seen
setting up a bomb in a Cobalt generator
somewhere in the ship after a while it
blows up near the terror lab
Harrison Krueger are taken aback by the
explosion and they quickly Rush inside
the facility where the giant spaceship
has been parked fortunately no
casualties are reported and the injured
are taken to the medical center
meanwhile Captain William and the others
inspect Ground Zero and find no future
graffitied on the wall confirming that
it was a deliberate explosion but
instead of announcing the news to
everyone the captain lies that it was an
accidental methane gas explosion he does
this so that no one can point fingers at
his governance the explosion also puts
Harris on the defense mode and he tells
Kruger that setbacks are to be expected
on projects of this scale however
Krueger is not satisfied and she demands
access to surveillance footage elsewhere
gold goes to the lower decks to meet a
man named Dwight who is responsible for
handling the Cobalt generators he
inquires about the blast but Dwight
panics and attacks him before running
away despite this gold continues his
investigation and learns that the
explosion on Deck 23 that killed his
parents 20 years ago was also caused by
a Cobalt generator he hypothesizes the
the Dwight must have learned it from
someone who could be connected to
lorelei's murder Galt is sure that
Stokes didn't kill Lorelei because he
didn't even know how to use the gun when
he tried to shoot him shortly after when
gold goes to check deck 23 Harris and
his assistant go into panic mode it
turns out because of the explosion the
other side of deck 23 isn't airtight
anymore and the crew inside can hear
noises coming from outside this poses a
risk of exposing the truth about the
projects as Harris and others maintain
pin drop silence golt locates Dwight and
they fight ensues during the tussle the
latter somehow manages to get away and
start a bomb's timer this alarms Harris
and he orders everyone to evacuate the
place immediately fortunately gold
manages to Defuse The Bomb but Dwight
dies in the process Krueger blames the
death on Harris and in his defense he
explains that he doesn't intervene
because the aim of the project isn't to
protect the crew but to learn from them
however Harris has proven to be lying
when he's seen gifting Dr Juliet's
seahorse necklace to his wife this
indicates that he was the one who
entered Christa's room and stole the
necklace at the same time Krueger starts
conducting research of her own and
learns that several scientists involved
in the Ascension project were found dead
and many went missing in the 1960s
meanwhile at the ship everyone is
preparing to get their regular shots
when it's Christa's turn she backs away
as she has visions of someone tampering
with the inoculations hence to encourage
her the librarian takes the shot instead
however as soon as she does so she
collapses on the grounds much to
everyone's horror this further
infuriates Kruger and she demands
answers Harris explains that they were
merely inoculations meant to strengthen
the immune system which has been
weakened by artificial lights recycled
air and repetitive diets the librarian
apparently collapsed because she took
the medicine that was meant for Krista
he then reveals that Krista is 16 hours
overdue for her shot and worries that
she may suffer from violent convulsions
if she doesn't take it so Harris tries
to trick her into eating the medicine by
adding it in her milk however the little
girl senses something unusual and dumps
the milk on the floor hence foiling his
plan most not even that good for you
anyway meanwhile Kruger decides to meet
Eva author of a website that has kept
track of all the scientists from the 60s
that died or went missing during their
meeting Eva alleges that the government
used President Kennedy's charity as a
cover to abduct children from their
parents for the project geez jeez she
later an unknown man goes after Krista
and tries to forcefully inoculate her
however the man ends up hurting himself
and the little girl manages to get away
next golt finds Krista with the man's
blood on her dress and takes her to Dr
Juliet after she has cleaned up gold
personally speaks to her and finally
convinces her to take the shot after a
while Juliet's husband Dr Robert Bryce
prepares her for the shot and during
this Krista reveals about the array of
Visions she's been having as of late
some of them are falling off of the Twin
Tower a war in the desert that never
ends and drowning in an ocean she also
claims that she saw Dr Bryce in the
maintenance tunnel where Lorelei was
killed hearing this the doctor becomes
enraged so he gags her and force
inoculates her meanwhile Harris and his
assistant Carrillo are stunned by Krista
having accurate Visions about events
that have actually happened on earth
like the 9 11 attacks Carrillo comments
that Christa is what the project has
been working towards Dr Bryce gets a
match on the blood sample from Krista's
dress and learns that it belonged to his
wife's Apprentice Mesmer however later
Mesmer is found dead in his room Krueger
also completes her investigation and
concludes that Harris has someone inside
the ship who plants guns for him and
stages radiation storms meanwhile gold
searches messmer's quarters but doesn't
find anything that links him to the
saboteurs he concludes that Messmer
killed himself out of guilt for failing
to inoculate Krista the scene then cuts
to the final day of austera a festival
where the winners of the birth Lottery
are announced since the ship's human
population must always remain constant
they are only allowed to procreate when
one of the passengers passes away
recently three people have passed away
so interested couples will submit their
profiles and the birth computer will
select three couples taking into account
their chances of producing healthy
Offspring soon the names are announced
among the winners are officer Duke and
his wife meanwhile Krista notices a
woman outside of her quarters so she
wanders out following her the woman
leads the girl to the party and she is
revealed to be none other than the ghost
of Lorelei just then someone starts
playing a video of Captain William
having coitus with her and everyone in
the room gasps while Krista starts
screaming uncontrollably from the
control room Harris watches everything
go down he rolls back the footage and
notes that Christa started reacting
before the tape even started playing it
seems as if the little girl has the
power of seeing the future Harris is
amazed and he calls it morphic residence
apparently his father had predicted that
it would take three generations for
someone on the ship to develop morphic
resonance on the other hand Krueger
pretends to be interested in the
fertility Lottery and uses it to steal
the keys to stokes's cell it's revealed
that the couples who procreate without
the fertility computer's blessing are
ostracized by the crew and they are
moved to the lower decks with their
children being labeled unclaimed later
Kruger submit it's a report highly
critical of Harris and this prompts
director Warren to show up again as
Harris argues with Warren Krueger sneaks
to Stokes his cell but the latter
attacks her and holds her hostage as he
drags her away he finally discovers the
truth about the Ascension this stuns
Stokes and he starts having a mental
breakdown however Krueger calms him down
and asserts that they must escape before
they are spotted and killed she also
claims that she wants to help him
because the whole project is unethical
when they reach outside Stokes breaks
into tears but Krueger encourages him to
collect himself soon they are approached
by a guard and they team up to
neutralize him Krueger gets injured in
the process and Stokes goes to the
nearby store and fetches medical
supplies at gunpoints afterwards the two
drive to a motel in the next scene
Warren and Harris learn about the Escape
so the former calls an armed contingent
from the TC group a billion dollar
conglomerate it turns out the project
was actually funded by this group and
they are not happy with Harris hiding
things from the company the group
effectively terminates him from his
position Harris panics as he is aware
that this means death is near he pleads
with Warren to give him a second chance
but in vain however she decides to keep
his assistant Carrillo as it was him who
exposed Harris to her aboard the ship
Duke learns that gold has started
investigating his wife for the murder of
Lorelei so he loses it and heads to the
beach to confront him at the same time
Krista again starts to have a vision she
foresees a violent fight between Duke
and gold so she immediately heads to the
beach worried she inadvertently uses
telekinesis to electrocute Duke and get
him off of gold however she soon loses
control of her power and ends up sending
current through the ship shutting it
down in the process Warren blames Harris
for the incident and orders her henchmen
to get rid of him immediately scared
Harris starts explaining about Krista
and how she has developed morphic
resonance this excites Warren and it's
confirmed that the main purpose of the
mission was morphic resonance wasting no
time Harris and others rush back into
the control room and learn that every
System including the backup generators
connected to the ship have gone offline
because of the electrical surge although
the ship is out of power the faux stars
are still illuminated and Harris
explains that his father hardwired The
Starlights into the ship's nuclear
reactor in order to ensure that the
illusion would never be shattered even
in the event of a power outage Harris
then suggests using the ship's nuclear
reactor to bring the system back up on
the ship toeback gets a faint TV signal
and reports it to Dr Bryce however the
latter dismisses it and sends him to
look for Nora immediately after tobac
leaves Dr Bryce pulls the plug on the
screen this reveals that he is aware
that this whole mission is fake and that
he is in cahoots with Harris meanwhile
Kruger meets up with the author from
earlier Eva and explains everything to
her she then reveals her plan to flee
abroad and claim Asylum before exposing
the whole Ascension project Eva tries to
discourage from fleeing and this is when
Kruger realizes that the author is also
working for the TC group Eva also comes
clean and the next second she shoots
Kruger dead she then goes after Stokes
only to realize that he has run away
meanwhile the crew scrambles to get the
power back up inside the ship and as a
result the oxygen also continues to
dwindle Captain William and golt go to
the lower decks to get the carbon
dioxide scrubbers back and viandra
becomes the captain in charge to send
everyone into their pods to save oxygen
she announces radiation alert protocols
Harris concludes that the chances of
getting the scrubbers back online is
extremely low therefore Warren decides
to send her henchman Medici inside to
get Krista out before she suffocates to
death meanwhile William and golt realize
that the scrubbers are Beyond repair so
they decide to retrieve lithium dioxide
and manually spread it throughout the
ship as carbon dioxide changes into
oxygen and water once it comes into
contact with lithium dioxide on the
other hand Christus senses that someone
is coming to take her Dr Bryce confirms
this saying that some very bad people
are coming this makes Krista roll her
eyes and she confronts Dr Bryce about
his bad actions lo and behold it's then
revealed that it was the Doctor Who
Killed Lorelei after she learned the
truth about the mission golden Williams
successfully spread lithium dioxide
throughout the ship with the help of
large ventilation fans and they restore
the oxygen just then Medici arrives and
Dr Bryce tries to stop him but the Goon
easily removes him from his way and
proceeds to take Krista away gold then
starts seeing Lorelei and she leads him
to Krista it turns out gold has also
developed resonance he attacks Medici
and a fight ensuse krissa again uses her
power and shockingly she makes both gold
and Medici disappear Into Thin Air
seeing all this Warren panics and tries
to contact Medici through the radio she
walks closer to the spaceship and taking
advantage of this opportunity Harris
pushes her into the ditch and kills her
the show ends with gold teleporting to
an unknown Planet subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching